on commence donc par parler de ce qui
s'est passé à la préfecture de police
et bien sûr surtout du profil du
terroriste michael harpon on a appris
que il l'avait par exemple il s'était
félicité de l'attentât contre charlie
hebdo c'était en 2015 et pourtant il n'y
a pas eu de signalement de cette
radicalisation
que s'est il passé il y at il eu un
dysfonctionnement majeur
christophe castaner s'est expliquée à
nouveau ce matin sur france inter
ce n'était pas forcément convaincant
mais jugez vous même et s'il n'y a pas
d' alerte il peut y avoir une faille
il peut y avoir ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière il n'y a hélas pas eu
d' alerte au bon niveau au bon moment
par rapport aux faits évoqués en 2015 ou
d'autres qui pourraient apparaître
ensuite mais qui ne sont pas apparues
aujourd'hui il a été couvert
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire qu'il
était découvert c'était un collègue de
travail
les collègues de travail ont parlé entre
eux ils ont jugé inutile désormais
m'exprimer selon rapport qui m'a été
remis le besoin de conseils pour gérer
la situation ils ont pensé qu'ils
pouvaient le va centrer mais le délégué
plusieurs signes a eu je le disais cette
cet homme qui se féliciter publiquement
auprès de ses collègues qui se
réjouissait plutôt de l'attentât contre
charlie il fréquentait une mosquées
salafistes
il semblerait qu'il ait mis un certain
nombre de distance entre avec les femmes
collègues qui ne voulait plus salués et
pourtant même au sein de la cellule
antiterroriste de la préfecture de
police de paris
ça n'a rien provoquer c'est un
dysfonctionnement comme le dit le
ministre ou s'éteint c'est une affaire
d'état
en tout cas le
la note dont parle le ministre de
l'intérieur qui est donc une note
publiée samedi par la directrice du
renseignement elle indique que beaucoup
de choses étaient connus sur le coupable
le meurtrier mais que ces choses
n'étaient pas arrivés jusqu'aux
autorités compétentes sachant que
laurent du neige était au cabinet de la
préfecture de police en 2015 quand il ya
eu notamment les signalements au autour
de faire les abdos donc ça apparaît
comme une espèce de défense expliquant
que finalement c'était le profil était
que de mickaël larpe ont été connus de
certains mais n'étaient pas connues de
ce qui aurait pu prendre une décision
peut-être que c'est vrai ça me paraît
quand même un tout petit peu bizarre
dans une structure comme la préfecture
de police qui est la structure la mieux
renseignés de france où les notes
pullulent sur énormément d'événements
sur énormément de personnes et il
apparaît extraordinaire qu'il n'y en ait
pas eu sur mickaël larpe ont ensuite il
faut savoir que depuis 2016 il ya des
cellules de veille des radicaliser qui
existe dans les établissements publics
et notamment dans les préfectures avec
des réunions qui sont parfois mensuel
donc pourquoi à la préfecture de police
il ne se passerait pas ce qui se passe à
la préfecture d'ajaccio demande ou de
strasbourg
donc on va voir pour le moment on n'a
pas d'éléments mais il me paraît tout à
fait
étrange qu'un certain nombre de
personnes et su si personne n'avait rien
su bomba très bien mais issus ces
signalements mais que ces signalements
ne soit pas arrivée jusqu'à des gens
dont le métier et d'exceller dans le
renseignement
il y avait quelque chose qui pour le
moment est encore assez flou qu'est ce
qui a pu se passer céline pina il ya une
hypothèse qui est que l'environnement de
mickaël larpe on à la future de police
de paris et qui était dans une forme de
déni ce qu alexis brézet le directeur du
figaro appelle le déni islamisme dans un
néologisme qui fait l'objet de son
éditorial de ce matin mais je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ce qu'a écrit
alexis brézet et notamment parce que
quand vous allez vers tous les documents
mentionnant la radicalisation qui ont
été produits par le gouvernement vous
avez déjà un premier point aveugle qui
est que la radicalisation sert à éviter
de prononcer le mot religion et encore
moins le mot islamisme donc on vous dit
on va lutter contre quelque chose en
prend soin de ne jamais le définir
ensuite quand on parle de lutter contre
la radicalisation ça s'arrête à prévenir
éventuellement un peu surveiller punir
il n'en est jamais question donc et
ensuite vous n'avez vous sentez bien en
vous lisez on est sûr sensibiliser
réorienter accentuée moi j'ai écrit
pendant des années des tracts électoraux
quand vous ne savez rien dire parce que
votre commanditaires vous a dit voilà on
va faire les 35 propositions puisque 35
c'est trop la classe et qu'il en a 10 il
faut bien en nourrir 25 andré banda vous
sensibiliser tous ces mots là je les
utilisais quand j'avais rien à dire
quand vous lisez ces documents vous vous
rendez compte que personne ne peut faire
remonter un signalement parce que ça
veut dire qu'il prend sur lui le fait de
définir lui même ce qu'elles
radicalisent et qu'il prend sur lui le
fait de traiter quelqu'un d'islamistes
qu'il prend sur lui de choisir lui-même
les éléments de preuve qui la mène et
qu'en plus dans ce cas là la hiérarchie
ce que ce qu'ont les collègues on en
parlait la personne chargée de faire
remonter des signalements a dit ok pas
de problème
vous faites un écrit ils n'ont pas voulu
dans l'administration quand on vous dit
vous me faites un écrit ça veut dire mon
gars si ça tourne mal
c'est toi qui payera les pots cassés
l'écrit c'est l'ouverture du parapluie
donc c'est très très compliqué de faire
remonter des signalements quand vous
avez un gouvernement qui est dans le
déni et qui ne donnent pas les outils
pour le faire si le ministre est dans le
déni comment voulez vous que la personne
qui a employé à la préfecture fasse ce
travail nous vous posons la question
selon vous la tacc de la préfecture de
police de paris est elle un scandale
d'état
et vous nous répondu sur twitter vous
tous chers internautes qui centre à nous
suivre en direct vous nous répondez oui
à 66%
est-ce aussi votre avis laurent david sa
maman c'est compliqué je me demande ce
que ça entraîne ce que ce que ça
implique si c'est un scandale détail si
on le pense si on a droit de le penser
qu est ce que ça implique une démission
de ken de castaner est-ce que c'est lui
qui est au bout de la chaîne de
responsabilités donc ce serait à lui de
payer les pots cassés 2,7
cet acte là de ski c'est ce qui s'est
passé je sais pas dans ladite note dans
la note que vous évoquez il ya ceux il
ya cette évocation de du signalement qui
a été demandé à deux des fonds des
fonctionnaires on leur demande de
formez un papier de femmes note et c'est
à ce moment là qu'il ne la font pas et
qu'ils se disent tous ensemble et les
mots de la notes et les mots de la
lettre de la directrice du renseignement
sont les suivants on est une famille on
est habitués à travailler dans un cadre
familial qui fait qu' on se parle de
tout on se connaît tous on se cooptent
eux mêmes ce qui fait que oui c'est une
affaire qui se règle en famille qui
aurait dû se régler en famille c'était
leur désir à eux
est-ce qu'on veut vous parler du coût de
scandales d'état je sais pas si tout le
monde est au courant et s'ils ont aussi
on le sait tous et si c'est la volonté
de la façon de faire de la préfecture
bon c'est peut-être les us et coutumes
et les méthodes peut l'être aussi at il
une autre explication à ce qui s'est
passé c'est la difficulté de renvoyer et
même de muter un fonctionnaire qui s'est
radicalisée
écoutez ce qu'en disait ce matin marc
trévidic qui lui-même est ancien juge
anti terroriste
il était il était invité de france info
il ya une grande différence entre le
recrutement initial et des gens qui sont
déjà un fonctionnaire quand il
radicalise puisque c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'empêcher quelqu'un d'entrée
dans la fonction publique régaliennes
que après de le virer s'il se radicalise
c'est très difficile quand quelqu'un est
déjà en poste et fonctionner avec le
statut de la fonction publique de dire
vous vous radicaliser et quelques petits
signes
ils y apprennent du droit comment
comment on fait pour se débarrasser de
la personne en question c'est très
compliqué autorisé que cela n'avait su
s'il ya une espèce d'impuissance même
face à une radicalisation qu'on constate
parce que ça a été le cas dans ce
service
alors c'est tout si cette histoire est
très étonnante et comme souvent le juge
trévidic a raison ce qui est étonnant
c'est que dans ce pays depuis les années
80 on a fait 17 lois antiterroristes et
sur les 17 lois antiterroristes on n'a
pas réussi à trouver une disposition
pour pouvoir virer quelqu'un qui se
radicalise quelle que soit la
radicalisation je rappelle quand même la
radicalisation ne porte pas que sur les
musulmans parce que oui l'islam
la radicalisation c'est un processus
vous êtes radicaliser d'extrême droite
pour devenir radicaliser ultragauche
radicaliser ceci ou cela c'est le
processus c'est pour ça qu'ont certains
campagne à logements
mais c'est pour ça comme tu commettre
les attentats au couteau en criant au
bout des choses il ya des choses qui se
passent en thaïlande ou en birmanie la
france mais bien sûr mais ce que je sais
c'est quand c'est comme madame danielle
obono par exemple disait qu'il n'y a pas
de processus de radicalisation c'est
absurde c'est un terme de police mais le
souci c'est que quand même on doit
pouvoir en sur dix cette réforme on n'a
pas fait une seule loi pour permettre de
virer des ne serait ce que des policiers
ou des agents régalien qui poserait
problème quel que soit le problème c'est
un souci on a un premier ministre qui
dans le parisien dimanche dit il serait
il serait bon que dorénavant on fasse un
contrôle sur tous les non pas tous les
fonctionnaires n'ont pas tous les agents
de police surtout ceux qui s'occupent du
contre terrorisme mais c'est une blague
salaires s'est pas fait et là où il ya
c'est vrai les sondages paraît-il non
mais et moi je vous dis je pense que
c'est un scandale d'état
parce que monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur castaner a couvert une
affaire il a couvert parce que la
république souveraine avec nos experts
non à la dérive annoncé à la sortie de
50 de la préfecture de police
oui quand il a dit que tant que quand il
est dit que c'était s'est interrogé
comment est un drame
à 16h05 au sein de république souveraine
avec nous quelques experts
nous avons trouvé qui est que c'était
nickel harpon qui était à dire pp qui
était handicapée
on avait sa page facebook et vous à
regarder sa page facebook à 16h05
trois heures après l'attentât mais on
n'est pas au service de on est pas on
n'a pas les moyens du ministère de
l'intérieur
donc cette information il l'avait tout
autant c'est un choix qui a été fait il
pense qu'il a voulu délibérément caché
que c'était un islamiste mais oui parce
que on ne sait pas parler d'eux et
surtout monsieur castaner qui est quand
même tout le monde le sait est
extrêmement peu compétent dans les
affaires de police et heureusement que
alors en une et ce derrière lui pour lui
tenir
un an qu'on parle très mal des questions
de terrorisme
il a signé une loi une débat sur
l'immigration qui commence comme vous
l'avez dit aujourd'hui encore je pense
qu'ils se sont dit oulala
si on annonce que c'est un ca
radicaliser ça va partir dans la
mauvaise direction pas celle que l'on
voulait que cela prenne alors que on
peut rappeler que les premières victimes
des islamistes mais des terroristes
islamistes ce sont des musulmans dans
les pays musulmans 95% d'entre eux c'est
trente mille morts dans les pays de
culture ou religion musulmane depuis les
attentats charlie hebdo
donc ce sont des ennemis de tout le
monde dès ce sont des fascistes et qui
doivent être dénoncées comme tel et
c'est un problème de ne pas pouvoir de
ne pas pouvoir le faire il ya cette peur
là laurence pinard céline tison pardon
l'idée de dire que le danger c'est de
voir dans tout français musulmans un
danger potentiel
il ya cette peur là mais j'allais dire
ce type d'attitude renforce encore plus
le danger pour les musulmans c'est à
dire que pour ya une peur pareil il faut
faire la distinction très stricte entre
islamistes et musulmans
koné sur les islamistes en fait ce qu'il
faut c'est rendre coûte le fait d'être
islamistes aujourd'hui le fait d'être
islamiste n'est pas coûte contraire il
vous protège et ils vous donnent une
sorte de totem d'impunité il faut
renverser ça pour renverser sa wii il
faut changer les lois
quand c'est nécessaire mais surtout il
faut poser quand même un certain nombre
de problèmes
qu'est ce qui choque c'est que au sein
finalement de l'endroit qui devrait être
le plus protégé de france on a pu
abattre
les gens chargeaient de notre sécurité
aujourd'hui tout le monde se dit mais en
fait personne n'est protégé nulle part
ensuite le ministre dit bah c'est la
faute des collègues qui n'ont pas parlé
j'allais dire ils doivent être très à
l'aise les gens qui ont autour d'eux un
collègue qu'il soupçonne d'être
radicaliser dans ce type de l'ambiance
on est quand même en train de passer
complètement à côté de la plaque en
avait un ministre qui venus pleurer à la
télé pour nous dire j'ai rien fait
garder moi ce qu'on attendait de lui à
la limite je comprends pas qu'il n'ait
pas démissionné mais admettons mais ce
qu'on attendait de lui c'est à ce moment
là une prise de conscience oui nous
disent oui ok il ya eu un gros souci
un gros problème voilà ce qu'on va vous
proposer pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de radicaliser au moins dans
l'armée au moins dans la police au moins
dans l'éducation nationale
ça me paraît quand même un exemple pour
le faire rien à ce que le mouvement
n'est pas déjà trop
ainsi on verra d'hiver parce que les
lois que l'on invoque anti
discrimination qui empêche de muter
quelqu'un quand l'un des intérêts
supérieurs sont en jeu la personne peut
tout à fait de licencier plv aux
prud'hommes et elle gagne ou pas mais
enfin on n'est pas obligé ça c'est pas
vrai surtout dans le service de
renseignement de la pp mais moi je crois
que cette affaire
en plus de l'événement tragique et
historiques comme le dit gilles kepel de
cet attentat est aussi le moment de la
consommation du divorce et c'est très
inquiétant entre la parole publique
qu'elles soient politiques ou
médiatiques et l'opinion et je crois que
la légèreté avec laquelle le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est exprimé au journal de
13 heures la légèreté avec laquelle le
premier ministre s'est exprimé dans le
journal du dimanche en répondant à trois
questions
dupuis en passant retraite et à d'autres
sujets comme si ça n'était pas central
alors que on est dans un événement aussi
important que charlie aussi important
que les crimes commis par mohamed merah
là il ya quelque chose qui n'a pas été
pris en compte et j'avoue que je
m'interroge sur le choix de la
présidente du président la république de
ne pas prendre la parole pour parler aux
français comme père de la nation comme
l'ont fait avant lui françois hollande
nicolas sarkozy ou où jacques chirac
quand il y avait des événements de la
sorte
donc là il ya quelque chose d'absolument
décalé entre la tragédie de l'événement
et la parole politique et je le répète
médiatique puisque à mon avis certains
journalistes se sont fait parfois
intoxiqué donc ont défendu alors à mon
avis ils ont fait leur boulot on leur a
dit que c'était un déséquilibré alors
que ça ne l'était pas mais du coup ça
entretient la défiance qui est déjà
extraordinairement développer dans le
pays
donc voilà c'est cesser cet événement en
plus de ce qu'il est à mon avis marque
une rupture dans le rapport
aux autorités établies défiance qu'on a
pu mesurer ya quelques jours encore avec
la par exemple lincendie de l'usiné
exactement où le gouvernement n'était
pas crédible quand le meurtre se passe
au sein de la préfecture de police de
paris que le ministre de l'intérieur et
des renseignements erronés
il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas erroné
pas voulu nommer un lien penser ça je
vous donne le point de vue de nos
internautes sur twitter avec ce affirme
que cette attaque est l'illustration de
la faillite de notre renseignement
apparemment il n'y a aucun précédent
d'événements de ce type à l'étranger mk
brownie tôt pour moi la taxe n'est pas
un scandale d'état mais une illustration
de grands manquements dans celle d'un
service
et puis babineau qui souligne à son tour
que il est incroyable que l'assaillant
ce soir réjouis de l'attentât de charlie
hebdo sans qu'il y ait eu de signalement
il est là le dysfonctionnement nous dit
il non pas son un autre événement de ce
week-end c'est la manifestation des
opposants à la pma sans père ou la pma
pour tout vous savez que ce projet est
dans la loi bioéthique qui est
actuellement en cours d'examen au
parlement il ya une réelle mobilisation
hier 74 mille cinq cents manifestants
selon un organisme indépendant 600 mille
selon les organisateurs
en tout cas il y avait du monde c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle estime yaël
brawn peavey lé député la république en
marche
les personnes peuvent exprimer leurs
opinions quel qu'il soit et c'est ça
l'essentiel on ne pense pas tous la même
chose sur les questions bioéthiques
parfois même au sein de notre groupe ou
même vraiment chacun se pose des
questions c'est des questions qui sont
perturbantes
et donc il est tout à fait normal qu'une
partie de la population puisse exprimer
des avis divergents mais franchement
c'est cette manifestation elle m'a
semblé être bienvenu parce que elle a
permis à cette frange de la population
de s'exprimer
laurent david savard a même les
organisateurs on semble être un petit
peu débordé par le succès puisqu'ils ont
dû à mettre à deuxième un deuxième
parcourt un deuxième cortège parce que
le premier était et est embouteillée
est ce que ça dit quelque chose une
forme de mobilisation ça dit quelque
chose mais ça dit aussi quand on les
écoutait certains prenaient la parole en
nous disant en somme on sait qu'on a
peut-être pas perdu mais on témoigne
notre prix présence massive est un
témoignage du combat qu'on mène et qu'on
mènera et qu'on continuera de mener et
c'est les mêmes qui sont dans dans dans
la rue à six mois à un an de distance et
qui ressortiront pour d'autres pour
d'autres causes
moi ça m'interroge on sort beaucoup et
on sort massivement mais on s'est
peut-être qu'on a déjà perdu et on le
laisse penser on veut qu'on le laisse
laisse croire ils sont aussi pacifique
ces manifestants
j'ai kuzmanovic ça ça contraste avec
certains débordements des gilets jaunes
qui ont obtenu quelque chose du coup
certains se disaient pas nous en casse
rien donc
donc on obtiendra peut-être pas les
coupes du gouvernement alors gillet